Greeks voted with their feet sweeping
the far left cereza and its charismatic
young leader Alexis tsipras into power
after years of living with austerity
which such as you keep plummet by
twenty-five percent can serezha turn
brisas fortunes around the ambitious new
cameras that want to renegotiate a deal
on the country's public debt but will
you partners play ball at a meeting of
the economic and Monetary Affairs
Committee Germany's Finance Minister
Wolfgang schäuble hinted towards a
showdown with Greece Xperia and n
problem only mine land agreement under
sold a body mouseland problem he begin
an email so how's ur enters in dr.
stolen it so how's its allure salon de
Sala davit head can heaven as man
problem occurs in cannabis accounted for
blame resume Nikita senses the Brussels
chamber played host to a plenary midweek
top of the agenda anti-terrorism
measures as EU countries scramble to
find solutions here to at Parliament any
Peas debated a europe-wide approach as
well as showing optimism for a deal on
climate change at the UN conference in
Paris this December which will see a
drastic cut in emissions a reminder of
the true horror of war as people paid
their respects at Parliament 70 years
after or schwitz over a million mostly
Jewish people were killed at the camp at
the hands of the Nazis before it was
liberated survivors and commemorate errs
have warned that we cannot repeat
mistakes of the past we are strong we
have power we have influence and this
applies us every second to stand up when
the evil is appearing and to say not
with us